think like it would have been special it's kind
of like the way i feel about terminator 2. like
i love the theatrical version so much and that's
one of my favorite movies of all time and then
when i saw the special edition i'm like oh my god
i liked it even more now yeah and that's kind of
what this scene does for me like is it needed and
maybe not necessarily but would it add absolutely
oh buddy the code it's been deciphered at reddit
because i'm batman all right guys looks
like we got our official joker scene
released uh this is a deleted scene from
the movie the batman featuring barry ko
gaga matt reeves has talked extensively about
this particular scene it's like five minutes
long i'm excited to see it if you guys can leave
a like that'd be very much appreciated check
out all the batman coverage you've had over
the past month let's get into action people
dog
oh
press
isn't it almost our anniversary there's
a serial killer i want your respect
first anniversary paper
what makes you think i'm so cheap i
thought you'd be curious why it's so cute
you think i cut off in this
stuff don't you you're pictures
let's chew his fingernails off
oh it's sinister i love the way
they're shooting this violence
he likes little puzzles doesn't he so
meticulous i keep it planning this at life
i know who he is
framing
yeah he's a nobody wants to be somebody
the mayor the commissioner
yeah he's got ambition you think his motive
is political oh no this is very very personal
oh my god so silence of the lambs i love
it yes these people have all wronged him
probably goes way back unhealed wounds stolen
much money why is he writing to me maybe
he's a fan of yours good call or maybe
he's got a grudge against you too
maybe you're the main course
any theories not yet really
but something is different this time this is
very upsetting to you let's get back to him
you are so much more fun to talk about me what
are you here to talk about i want to know how he
thinks you know exactly how he thinks have you
read this file back and forth solid man into
makes you look soft
i'm wasting my time
okay i'll tell you what i really think i think
you don't really care about his motives whether
he loves or hates you i think somewhere deep down
you're just terrified because you're not
sure anyone huh you think they deserve it
ah [ __ ] love that scene a brilliantly shot scene
that's one of the best deleted scenes i've ever
seen yeah that's not i don't mean that in any
hyperbolic way that is legit one of the best
deleted scenes i've ever seen that's like his own
little short film right there it's like a batman
fan film that some youtuber was like barry kogan
should have gotten his own movie or something so
i'm gonna make a fan film out of it and it feels
that way i'm trying to think what scene this would
have come after if that makes sense like what
is the placement of the scene after and before i
think this really would have complemented the film
quite well especially for when he actually does
encounter riddler and discovers that a lot of what
joker was alluding to was actually correct i love
all the signs of the lambs types of vibes that
this was omitting throughout i do think though
that this scene in like an extended cut would
definitely complement the film and really work
because a lot of times you watch these deleted
scenes you're like they're not really necessary
however i think it would actually elevate the
scene in a lot of ways i get for runtime how you
could have asked it not gonna lie like i could
see why it wasn't necessary to be in the movie
but i do love the world building it does i do love
that line about like the anniversary establishing
where it's at i love the way it's shot where it's
he's always obscured only captured in these like
minimalistic reflections and and the close-ups
that are so disgustingly morbid intimate but john
what'd you think of like barry coken's performance
oh i i loved it man and it's funny because in the
dialogue there's so many little uh things that you
could take as nods to previous iconic joker lines
and yeah like now post heath ledger especially
i think there's that kind of albatross of like
are they just gonna go for that or they gonna do
their own thing and i really really liked what he
did here and i liked the sort of koi quality that
he played it with this sort of almost flirting
with batman you know he's he's they said he's a
proto version he's not the joker that we know just
yet and i get that sense while also feeling you
know obviously when that smile comes up that grin
and just certain of the jabs that he's giving
to him like you get that quintessential you
know yin to the yang and yeah barry kogan
i mean i i really like the sort of slow
draw like i want to go back and re-listen to the
scene because there are certain lines that almost
get sort of fuzzed out in the just tone and the
eerie intimacy that is happening it's so funny
because like this barrier of the glass is such a
presence in and of itself and it's always you know
obscuring like you said his face or it's always
you know out of focus or something like that they
make you imagine what the front half of his head
looks like by showing you the back of it showing
you his hands and his fingernails and like all the
mutilation that this guy has gone through and and
yeah i really like that sort of seething it's like
a calm chaos almost eerie because you can imagine
what a maniacal more fully powered joker would
be like and at this moment though i really love
that rapport between him is like yeah you know
you clearly put me here i know you and i have a
fixation on you but yeah i'll take a look at your
little file whatever i feel like yeah this is a
scene that would have certainly complemented the
movie and maybe just you know would have needed
like a third piece or something to make it fully
rounded i mean i love just the way that he's kind
of predicting the whole thing and maybe that was
a fact or two maybe they're like well he's just
gonna be right by the end so maybe we don't want
to foreshadow that all directly too soon but um i
i got such a huge kick out of their back and forth
and i mean you know pattinson is it's just like
this is the most consistent performance because i
felt like i was just back in the theater watching
the movie again true i think thematically though
it complements it exceptionally well by every
time you get to the end of the batman and then
you know one of riddler's goons is saying i'm
vengeance and batman's realizing like this is the
product of him like batman has helped inspire this
and the way how ridler saw a reflection of himself
within batman joker has a line in there where he's
telling batman that part of you thinks he maybe
he was right and that little extra umph probably
would have helped elevate the movie a little bit
more even though i think the movie's like pretty
great i'm like oh that would have just given me
that extra little nudge that i didn't think i
wanted or needed but i i think like it just would
have been special it's kind of like the way i feel
about terminator 2 like i love the theatrical
version so much and that's one of my favorite
movies of all time and then when i saw the special
edition i'm like oh my god i liked it even more
now yeah and that's kind of what this scene does
for me like is it needed and maybe not necessarily
but would it add absolutely well and this one it's
funny because of the you know great people have
had about the ending scene with the joker this
doesn't feel at all tacked on like it absolutely
feels like a scene that would have flowed probably
pretty would have made it better yeah yeah and to
me it feels like it probably happened pretty early
on you know maybe after that first investigation
of the mayor's mayors of the da's apartment with
the police and all that stuff well yeah i think a
lot of people felt the same way and how that joker
scene and the theatrical felt cut felt tacked on
whereas here it would have actually made it feel
more natural like the setup that you're building
to when they do cross paths would have been like
an oh [ __ ] like you already know it's the joker
right when he starts talking as opposed to the
movie and the theatrical version making it feel
like we're about to reveal to you it's the joker
but if the joker's already established in the
movie and then you see that he's familiar with
his work actually seeing the crime scene photos
getting acquainted and like really understanding
who riddler is it it adds more tension to it
in the sense of joker then when he is befriending
him at the end of the batman movie he's like oh i
can manipulate this guy because i know who he is
already yeah it completes it yeah so then it makes
for a good setup for part two even though matt
reeves said he doesn't know if the joker's gonna
be the main villain in the batman too i think it
would be a better setup for it and uh yeah i like
the eeriness to this but guys what did you think
about it i thought barry kogan did a great job
i still want to see him like more but from
what we got it does feel like inspire from
other things it's like i've seen so many different
joker interpretations as many of you have it feels
like a bit of a combination of what heath ledger
did combined with the i don't remember which one
came first either jerome or jeremiah but whatever
the second one the latter one is in gotham that
um my god that beautiful actor cameron monahan
played in gotham it feels like a combination
of of those two to me but also with the messed up
makeup is especially feeling like actually both of
the versions that uh freaking cameraman had played
alright guys leave your thoughts down below thank
you so much for being here subscribe click that
bell hit that like button and hey let's do it
daniel gallagher daniel my friend look we've made
so many jokes about you working as a pharmacist
and i do want to say that if you want to get a
promotion you got to work at an insane asylum man
look at all the amounts of prescription you
would be dishing out left and right to all
kinds of crazy people and knowing the kind of
crazy people that are here in the world of arkham
oh man you become influenced you need
some medication that medication would
stop working and then you would eventually
need actual help yourself you'd be an inmate
and my god the amount of friends you would make
i know you're a big batman fan but come on man
life can get a little dull if you're
doing the same thing over and over again
it's time to get a little nuts so get a little
nuts with some of the people that you're helping